what are the ingredients for an
industrial revolution take some new
energy sources add a dash of
cutting-edge communications technology
and top it all off with an emerging mode
of transportation when our society goes
through an industrial revolution we spur
economic growth and completely change
the world we live in we've seen the
effects of two already so how would
things change if we had a third this is
what if and here's what would happen if
there was a third Industrial Revolution
according to economist Jeremy Rifkin
we're already on the cusp of a third
Industrial Revolution a convergence of
the Internet renewable energy and
automated transportation if we embrace
this transformation
it could be centralized nearly every
industry on earth giving more power to
the people how would this be an
important weapon against climate change
how long can a civilization exist
surviving on a finite resource like
fossil fuels well we might find out
sooner than we'd like
according to Rifkin our current economic
system and our planet will eventually
expire if we don't move away from a
carbon-based world so how do we do that
well it's already started and it was all
triggered by our embrace of the World
Wide Web before the Internet the cost to
spread your knowledge and information
was pretty expensive for example let's
say you wanted to share your ideas
through a newspaper not only would you
have to worry about the initial cost of
setting up shop but you'd also have to
spend money on every single copy you
made and distributed nowadays after the
initial cost of accessing the internet
you can produce unlimited copies of your
ideas and get them out to millions of
people without any further spending this
phenomenon is known as zero marginal
cost and it could be the foundation of
the third Industrial Revolution with the
internet hundreds of millions of people
are producing and sharing music videos
news blogs and ebooks essentially for
free bypassing the cap
market altogether we don't have to rely
on a couple of giant corporations to
feed us all our information and now that
phenomenon is expanding from the virtual
world to the physical world of goods and
services for instance let's say you and
a bunch of neighbors want to start your
own power grid based on renewable energy
well with today's technology you could
do that and then you could even use that
grid to power driverless cars to run a
local rideshare program you'd be
creating a sustainable economic system
that would essentially cost you nothing
after the initial set up if society
embraces the possibilities of using the
Internet renewable energy and automatic
transportation together it could
restructure our economy traditional
corporations would be disrupted and the
power would be returned to the local
communities we'll also be able to
collect a lot more information about the
world around us allowing our economy to
operate at top efficiency as we continue
to place sensors on just about
everything we'll be able to track things
like the flows of Natural Resources
traffic and shipments all this available
data will allow us to increase
productivity and decrease waste and our
ecological footprints dramatically so
maybe our future's not so bleak after
all or maybe all this global
connectivity will just open us up to a
whole new type of threat but that's a
topic for another what-if